direkt
gerade über die games
gerade von verfechtern angezogen ich
finds noch realistischer geworden aber
so ich habe hier noch zwei leute
getroffen
ein gerichtstermin steht für die aussage
viel spaß und zehn mal wieder nicht
alleine sondern zusammen mit
so sollen die karten gegen den schon
tiefer gespielt habe dass die grünen
wahrscheinlich eingewendet trainer den
ich ja gar nicht vorgestellt hast wie
alt bist du oder sechs jahre 66 alles
klar okay das ist schon ein bisschen
älter als ich bin auf ihr warum genau
hast du bock mitzufahren
weil ich einfach mal weg muss weil ich
vollkommen einfach mal ein bisschen um
die gamescom ich hätte es fertig ist
okay schwarzmarkt gerade einfach perfekt
also passt auf jeden fall auch mit dabei
einer der mitfahrer wer noch dabei ist
von alexei black sea wieso willst du
alles gedacht habe du bist du dabei wie
so wie du hast du bock auf nichts wie
weg
wie das heute anders ist
diese stressigen stellen mal probiert
meinen moment zu chillen selber vor
werden jetzt ein aus und würden irgendwo
an einem geschützten ort genau dass er
das nicht super es wäre das wäre echt
richtig klasse dazu nicht nur die zwei
männer sondern sogar mit bauen alles
klar das ist auf jeden fall einfach die
gamescom wird halt irgendwie von oft
angesprochen was natürlich auch cool ist
allerdings müssen wir jetzt echt ein
bisschen weiter und swing story an die
die irgendwie nichts bekommen haben
fotos von aber ich bin halt echt auch
noch ein bisschen angeschlagen ich
möchte einfach nicht jeden umarmt weil
ich verletzt bin
aber wir werden uns jetzt wahrscheinlich
in ein auto begeben und irgendwo
hinfahren wo ist ein bisschen
schwieriger ist so freunde besitzen
jetzt im auto zusammen mit alex zusammen
mit unseren anderen du musst noch mal
eben vorstellen kurz hallo ich bin der
marius
wir fahren jetzt nach da lernen wo auch
immer das nicht der fall stunde lang hin
und werden dort dann an einen schönen
see gehen der vorne werden wir schon die
ganze zeit ganz fleißig gefilden
hochaktiver die kamera weg alles klar
die kids nicht die bis 70 zentimeter
vorne wären wir auf jeden fall ein
bisschen gefilmt und wenn wir dann da
sind melden wir uns wieder wir haben
hier oben auch noch einige proben statt
und zwar wird das alles hier gefilmt und
es wird auf einem kanal hochgeladen oder
er muss das nachher alles zusammen stein
aus unserer 1 stunden fahrt dürfte ich
bitte eine runde mitleid bekommen eine
runde mitleid für alex das ist aber wir
sind
und haben große
und auch große richtig große viel
größere deine mutter dich doch jetzt
auch mal fahren werden 600 gefragt dass
ich auch ein bisschen ich kann nicht ich
glaub ich fange an zu erzählen hat aber
dabei ist luca ich war egal autor sogar
monate immer wieder schön
wir freuen uns jetzt nur wenig internet
war
und das ist die aussicht
genau
wir fahren hier
ein
nicht so braun
so war es schon
da war jemand dem urlaub er ist gerade
dem 2 1 war fährt jetzt der mario
so freuen wir sind jetzt am see
angekommen und zwar als das der wie
heißt er denn noch mal irgendwas mit
karten seester ist jetzt werden wir uns
tretboote ausleihen und werden so ein
bisschen mit den tretbooten rumfahren
über den see vielleicht eine kleine
challenge machen wer weiß nach er sieht
man ja wieder bei alexy vecsey
beziehungsweise europa da mal ein paar
sachen und da gehen wir jetzt hin heiß
kronenburger see wurde mir gerade hier
von diesem kleinen wichtige verraten da
kronenburger see toll wundervolle für
die sieben sein stil ist der beste bot
dahin keine statements zu deinem boot
es ist super und warum weil es orange
ist und orange ist eine schöne phase
ein mitfahrer ist ja liebe ist sehr
wackelig 8 uhr heilige scheiße
vielleicht ist doch eine gute idee mit
der kamera alles klar
das rennen war ich habe
nach norden
ok freude wir sind jetzt gerade auf die
kamera ist gerade direkt die lutscher
dahinten dort im bild machen gerade noch
ein bootswechsel ich weiß warum wie sie
vollkommen zufrieden mit der nummer 7
zufrieden mit der siebel so brutal wie
kannst du auch die tatsache dass wir da
hinten einfach ein ferrari bot haben wir
natürlich nicht aber wir sind zufrieden
mit der 7
niemals ihr habt keine chance
wir sind zufrieden mit der 7
sitzen wir alle im auto wir waren gerade
tretbootfahren volleyball spielen das
aber noch alles für tolle und sind
bisher geplant
wir fahren jetzt auch alle was essen
wohin genau davon
luca ist ein absoluter dummkopf und hat
natürlich nicht das essen gefilmt lukat
außerdem nicht die rückfahrt gefilmt hey
was billig ist aber eigentlich nicht
mehr viel passiert damit waren alle mega
ko nachdem wieder trampelt gefahren
sondern habe dann einfach etwas gegessen
und sind danach zurück gefahren und ich
bin jetzt wieder einmal der wohnung und
bin komplett ko von diesem galt es war
halt alles mega anstrengend also wir
waren jetzt irgendwie zwölf studien
ganzen tag über unterwegs und wir waren
auf der gamescom waren trouble boot
fahren und haben dies gemacht dass
gemacht und blabla und ich sitze jetzt
wirklich einfach nur zu hause hat mir
gerade noch so eine schöne husten und
bronchitis gemacht den ich jetzt gleich
sitzen werde
wenn man ganze hals tut weh meine nase
sitzt du ich bin mega ko einfach von
video des games kommen aber es
vereinfachen mega krass spannendes und
geiles wochenende fand ich diese nicht
sie weckt uhr von europcar die ich
zusammen mit alex ii wechseln die bei
den zuschauern gemacht habe bildet jetzt
quasi den abschluss von beiden total
chaotischen wochenende auf dem video des
und gamescom ich versuche in den
nächsten tagen das war wieder regelmäßig
videos komme ich habe schon coole sachen
geplant auch wieder so richtig
behinderte spiele die ich cool
zusammenschneiden werde aber erst mal
wenn ihr euch dafür interessiert warum
wir das alles überhaupt gemacht haben
die ganze kampagne findet ihr den link
in der beschreibung wenn ihr wollt könnt
ihr gerne draufklicken ich hab auch die
ganzen youtuber die mit dabei waren in
der beratung verlängert und damit sehen
wir uns in einem anderen video wieder
und ich geh jetzt unbedingt schlafen
weil mehr als vier stunden im bett
verbringen tun sein